ينضم الينا الان من لاهاي زين دانور
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الفريق القانوني
لجنوب افريقيا اهلا بك
معنا الى اي اي درجه انتم واثقون بان
الملف
المقدم
سيقبل شكرا واسعدت مساء نحن
قدمنا قضيه تفصيليه كامله
وضحنا فيها عده امور اولا حقائق وجود
اباده جماعيه واجراءات او اعمال اباده
جماعيه
وشرحنا الدعم القانوني والتحليل القانوني
الذي يصف عمليه الاباده الج وهذا عناصر
جريمه الباده الجماعيه بالتفصيل والاهم من
ذلك بينا ان هناك النيه النيه فباد
الجماعيه تقوم على النيه السابقه النيه
على قتل مجموعه معينه الناس بطريقه شامله
واعتقد ان فريقنا القانوني وضح بشكل صحيح
ودقيق
اهميه النيه الموجوده لدى الحكومه
الاسرائيليه النيه الناجمه والتي سمعناها
من
الرئيس نتنياهو وبقيه المسؤولين وقاده
الجيش وحتى جنود الجيش الاسرائيلي وايضا
وضحنا بشكل واضح
لماذا ان الاجراءات الخاصه الاجراءات اللي
اطلبها فورا
لانهاء وبد وقت اطلاق النار وسماح
المساعدات الانسانيه امر ضروري وعاجل
وايضا لكن نوضح انه من الصعب جدا للقضاه
ان لا يعطوا لينا هذا الموافقه فورا بناء
على القضايا السابقه وبالتالي نحن نعتقد
نعتمد على القانون وعلى الحقائق وبالتالي
سيكون من الصعب ان قضيتنا لا تحصل على
الضوء الاخضر من المحكمه بالواقع بناء
على القضايا السابقه نستطيع ان نقول ان
الامر اذا ما لم تقبل فقد تك الامور فقط
لاسباب سياسيه قد يشعر قد يقرر القضاه بشء
مختلف لكن لا نعتقد ذلك لان ايضا وضحنا
لهم مدى اهميه هذه القضيه بالنسبه لكرامه
ومستقبل القانون الدولي بذاته وايضا
تاثيرات ذلك على ما يتعلق بالمحكمه العدل
الدوليه نفسها اذا لم تقرر او تز قرار
لصالح القضيه التي رفعتها جنوب افريقيا
واذا ما حصلتم على الضوء الاخضر ما الخطوه
التاليه
لذلك المهام الاساسيه بالاجراءات تتخذ
احكام فوريه بوقف اطلاق النار و وصال
المساعدات الانسانيه ونتفق ان اسرائيل ومن
يدعم اسرائيل لانهم يقولون ان يحترمون
القانون الدولي ان يحترموا امر المحكمه
ويقوموا بايقاف فور ل هجماتهم على شعب غزه
والسماح بالمساعدات الانسانيه لتدخل الى
غزه بطريقه غير معقله واعتقد هذه خطوه
مهمه الاوللا لاستعاده السلام اولا وعوده
السلام لشعب غزه و حقق لهم بعض العداله
للشعب الفلسطيني وايضا لوضع الاسس
المفاوضات والمحادثات لتوصل ال حل دائم
يكون
مفيدا للفلسطينين والاسرائيليين واعتقد
هذا هو العنصر هو العنصر المهم في الموضوع
الذي نطلبه ام ا بالنسبه ايضا
للملف المقدم ما المعتمد عليه بالدرجه
الاولى وتعتقدون انه لا يمكن لاي قاض ان
يغفله وانكم ستمد الى الخطوه التاليه بعد
ذلك ما المرتكز الاساسي في الدعوه التي
ترفعها
ان المرتكز الاساسي في قضيتنا هو ان جريمه
الاباده الجماعيه في معاهده الاباده وايضا
في معاهده روما تقوم ما يسمى بوجود النيه
الخاصه المزعومه عل ان نثبت بان هناك نيه
من قبل حكومه اسرائيل اليه على تدمير شعب
غزه بشكل كامل وان القضيه التي عرضناها
امام المحكمه
اليوم توضح تقدم كل الادله لا يمكن نقضها
وهذا يمثل اهم عنصر قدم لحد الان وهو يقوم
على الادله وبالتالي سيكون من الصعب على
القضاه ان يتجاهلوا هذه الادله التفصيليه
التي قدمت لهم ما مدى رضاكم
عن
هيئه القضاء التي شكلت لقبول الدعوه
المرفوعه من قبل جنوب افريقيا وبانها
ستكون عادله و تنظر بدون دوافع سياسيه كما
ذكرتها
انفا نحن نثق بان القضاه
سيستخدمون
خبراتهم المهنيه والمحامين المؤهلين مهنيا
وانم هذه المحكمه يقوم على بناء ما يقومون
به ونامل انهم س
بنيتهم
وموضوعيته اليوم شاهدنا هنا اثنين من
القضاه قبل بدء اجراءات كانوا قد اقسموا
اليمين بيكونوا موضوعيين وبالت نثق بان كل
القضاه سيمارسون عملهم بجي وموضوعيه
ويقومون يقوم قراراتهم على القانون وليس
على الجوانب السياسيه وعن القضايا
السياسيه كان هناك ردود من بنيامين
نتنياهو يتهم فيها جنوب افريقيا بالنفاق
كما يقول الى اي درجه تتوقعون بان الرد
الاسرائيلي ينبني على اسس قانونيه وليست
سياسيه نحن لا
نعلم ماذي سيكون الراي الاسرائيلي حجتهم
سن تسمعها ولكن ما نفترضه انهم سيحاولون
ان
يركزوا على بعض العناصر السياسيه كما ذكرت
انت التصريح الذي قدمه نتنياهو وايضا نثق
بان المحكمه سوف تقيم الاراء القانونيه
نقدمها وليس الاراء السياسيه لان ما
قدمناه اليوم كان قضيه قانونيه تفصيليه
فيها كل العناصر الادله التي تثبت وجود
جريمه اباده جماعيه وعليهم ان يفرض ذلك
على اسس القانون وليس السياسه وبالتالي
نامل ان يقدموا
رايا قانونيا وليس سياسيا اشعر ان الراي
القانوني قدمناه لا يمكن دحضه واننا قد
نرى ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه قد تحاول
استخدام
السياسه طريقه الدفاع الرئيسيه لها
بالنسبه للفريق القانوني الذي قام بدراسه
الملف والخروج بالنسخه النهائيه وتقديمها
هل هو فقط من جنوب
افريقيا
الفريق القانوني فعلا اختير اساسا من قبل
جنوب افريقيا فنحن شكلنا الفريق بانفسنا
وقسم قسم العلاقات الدوليه مع الرئاسه
ووزاره العدل وهذا يشمل قضاه جنوب افريقيا
خبراء القانونيون وايضا بعض الخبراء
الاجانب مقرهم في المملكه المتحده
المختصون في هذا الشان وبالتالي هذا فريق
مهني جدا ذو مهاره عاليه ويمكن نرى في ط
نرى ذلك في طريقه تقديمه ارائهم كلهم
اليوم والدول التي ساهمت معكم في تقديم
الدعوه جنوب افريقيا فقط ا هناك دول
اخرى في هذه المرحله فقط جنوب افريقيا
ولكن كما قد تعلمون بالوقت الذي قدمنا فيه
القضيه اليوم كان هناك 13 دول عبروا عن
دعمهم وان نتوقع ان بعضهم ان لم نقل
جميعهم اذا لم يك لديهم اي اعتراض على
الماده التاسعه من معاهده الجماعيه قد
يتدخلوا في هذه القضيه ونتوقع ان بعضهم
بالتاكيد سيفعل ذلك كما نتوقع دعما كبيرا
من منظمه التعاون الاسلامي وهذا يعني ان
كل اعضاء منظمه التعاون الاسلامي عبروا عن
دعمهم لجنوب افريقيا وكذلك شاهدنا ليله
امس ان الجامعه العربيه عبرت ايضا عن
دعمها افريقيا وقبل ذلك قبل هذه المقابله
وصلتني معلومات بان كوبا ايضا عبرت عن
دعمها لجنوب افريقيا وبالتالي هناك دعم
كبير جدا تظت به جنوب افريقيا من الجنوب
وانا نتوقع ان الكثير من هذه
الدول تنتهي الاجراءات المؤقته يتدخلون في
هذه القضيه عندما يتقرر الامر زين دنجور
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الفريق القانوني
لجنوب افريقيا شكرا لك